Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous parler d’un sujet passionnant
un sujet poétique,
voire carrément sensuel.
Encore une fois, les déchets.
Dans nos poubelles,
il y a un type de déchet
facilement reconnaissable
et même incontournable,
le biodéchet alimentaire.
Il s’agit de nos restes d’assiettes,
de préparations,
nos épluchures, découpes
de viande, de poisson,
les produits périmés, les invendus, etc.
Ce n’est pas un sujet anodin.
En France, aujourd’hui,
c’est un tiers de nos poubelles,
c’est plus de 130 kilos
par an par habitant.
Certains Français, les plus gaspilleurs,
vont jeter l’équivalent
d’une pizza XL par jour.
On en retrouve à tous les niveaux :
chez les restaurants,
les petits commerces,
la grande distribution, les marchés,
les ateliers
de transformation alimentaire, etc.
En France, tout ça, c’est 15 millions
de tonnes, c’est énorme !
C’est l’équivalent de 1500
tours Eiffel chaque année.
Vous me direz : « Ce sont des quantités
énormes, quelle est la situation ? »
Ce biodéchets, finalement,
il a un caractère incompressible,
difficile de l’éliminer complètement.
On est très loin du zéro déchet
et on continue d’en produire
des quantités énormes.
Incompressible ?
Oui, parce que tous, à la maison,
si on pouvait réduire ces déchets à fond,
on récupérerait nos croûtes de fromage
et nos épluchures d’oignons.
Mais j’ai envie de dire finalement,
on n’est pas tous candidats à Top Chef
et on n’arrive pas tous à sublimer le gras
du jambon en cromesquis gourmand.
Pour la plupart d’entre nous,
ce biodéchet finit direct à la poubelle.
Le biodéchet a aussi, par définition,
un caractère biodégradable,
donc un caractère
de conservation difficile à gérer.
Qu’est-ce qu’il advient
de ce biodéchet aujourd’hui ?
Dans les très grandes largeurs,
c’est-à-dire à 75%,
comme la plupart de nos déchets en France,
il est mélangé avec le reste
des ordures et finit
dans des solutions de destruction,
donc enfouissement -
l’enfouissement, ce sont
des décharges couvertes
qui avec le temps finissent
par faire des montagnes de déchets -
ou l’incinération, ce qui est un procédé
vraiment dommageable
et un gaspillage énergétique
pour ce biodéchet qui est
constitué à 75% d’eau.
Quelque part,
bonne nouvelle sur ce biodéchet,
il y a des réglementations très adaptées,
européennes puis françaises,
le Grenelle de l’environnement
et la loi de transition énergétique,
qui obligent le producteur
à trier ses biodéchets à la source
pour les envoyer dans des filières
de valorisation adaptées,
méthanisation ou compostage,
filières qui permettent un retour au sol
de cette matière organique.
Pourquoi aujourd’hui on n’est qu’à 25% ?
Une des raisons principales :
le manque de capacité de traitement,
de valorisation, en France.
Si on regarde l’existant,
d’un côté, il y a des solutions in situ
de type micro-compostage, qui ont
un réel intérêt pour le côté pédagogique
et qui sont très rapides
à mettre en œuvre.
Si vous avez un jardin, c'est la solution
idéale et ça ne date pas d'hier.
Il vous suffit de récupérer
un peu de branchages
et vous aurez un compost en sortie
à utiliser directement au jardin.
Pour un acteur un peu plus gros,
c’est envisageable
mais beaucoup plus délicat,
il faudra vraiment y mettre les moyens
pour surtrier les déchets,
bien gérer les intrants, se procurer
de la sciure ou un intrant carboné,
faire attention aux agrumes,
aux protéines animales,
bien retourner le compost
et entretenir le site.
Pour les acteurs qui sont plus gros
ou qui ont moins d’espace,
c’est quasiment mission impossible.
La gestion de déchets, c’est un métier,
avec des contraintes sanitaires fortes.
Vous serez plutôt
en conflit avec les voisins,
pas l'idéal en temps de confinement.
On retrouve la deuxième grosse catégorie.
Ce sont des solutions de très grande
échelle, type unité de méthanisation
ou plateforme de compostage,
qui ont l’avantage d’avoir
de très grosses capacités de traitement,
Donc c’est adapté pour les villes,
pour les grandes agglomérations,
ça permet de répondre à ces besoins-là.
C’est intéressant aussi pour le producteur
parce que c’est plus facile,
surtout pour les moins motivés
ou pour les plus contraints.
Il suffit de trier ses déchets
et de le mettre dans un bac approprié
qui va être collecté régulièrement
par le prestataire.
Cette solution est intéressante
et permet de traiter des gros volumes
mais a des écueils sérieux aujourd’hui.
Le premier élément,
c’est que des installations comme ça,
ça met très longtemps à se monter :
cinq, huit, dix, quinze ans parfois.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il y a des vrais problèmes
d’acceptabilité sur ces projets-là
de très grosses emprises foncières,
des stocks de matières à l’air libre
qui dégagent
des grosses nuisances olfactives,
un gros trafic local
et puis des distances logistiques
qui sont très tirées, parfois
sur plusieurs centaines de kilomètres.
Donc ce qui pèse sur l’environnement
et, bien sûr, sur les coûts de gestion.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’on pourrait faire
pour trouver une autre solution,
pour essayer d’améliorer
ce ratio de 25% ?
Chez Trion, on a développé une solution
qui se veut alternative et intermédiaire,
c’est-à-dire suffisamment petite
pour pouvoir s’implanter
en proximité des villes,
directement en péri-urbain,
et du coup, avoir une logistique
optimisée sans trajets superflus,
mais en même temps qui soit
suffisamment grande
pour répondre sérieusement aux contraintes
techniques et sanitaires
de la filière déchets.
Ça se traduit notamment par un besoin
d’avoir un modèle économique viable,
pérenne et des tarifs compétitifs,
parce que ça reste un levier important
pour le développement durable,
le coût de l’opération.
Voilà cette solution.
C’est aujourd’hui la plus petite unité
de méthanisation en biodéchets
qui injecte du biométhane en France et
très certainement en Europe et ailleurs.
C’est très compact, ça tient sur 2500 m²,
l’équivalent de quatre terrains de tennis.
Et sur cette surface,
on va pouvoir adresser les besoins
d’environ 20 000 à 130 000 habitants
pour produire une énergie
renouvelable constante
à hauteur de dix gigawatt-heures par an.
Ces projets se développent
très rapidement :
en seulement deux ans, c’est une solution
à une activité complète, réplicable,
et qui ne nécessite finalement
qu’un foncier d’implantation
pour pouvoir se développer.
Les véhicules fonctionnent au bio GNV,
qu’est-ce que c’est ?
C’est le gaz naturel véhicule.
C’est intéressant parce que c’est du gaz
produit directement à partir des déchets.
Sur l’unité, les camions vont
s’avitailler avec ce carburant-là.
Quand on additionne ce type de carburation
avec le modèle de logistique réduit,
c’est une économie de l’ordre
de 240 kilos de CO2
évités par tonne de biodéchets valorisés.
Comment ça fonctionne concrètement ?
Les déchets collectés sont
acheminés sur le site
et à l’arrivée, on va avoir une première
étape de séparation des erreurs de tri
et aussi des emballages, qui vont
repartir dans des filières de destruction.
Puis ce qui nous intéresse, le reste,
c’est une pulpe de biodéchets
qui va passer par différentes étapes
qu’on appelle de digestion.
Je vous avais promis du glamour.
Cette digestion, c’est quoi ?
Ce sont des silos fermés
dans lesquels on fait
tout simplement un élevage de bactéries
Que font les bactéries ?
Dans les bonnes conditions
de température et de pH,
elles vont digérer, dégrader cette matière
pour produire d’une part du biogaz,
qu’on va épurer et réinjecter
dans le réseau de gaz naturel.
Donc là, on a une vraie opportunité
de le faire localement avec des déchets.
La partie qui reste
en fin de dégradation bactérienne,
on retrouve une matière fertilisante
organique qu’on appelle un digestat -
désolé, c’est toujours glamour -
et cette matière, on va la distribuer
auprès d’un agriculteur partenaire,
qui, là aussi, constitue une véritable
alternative aux engrais minéraux
qui ont souvent
des provenances très lointaines.
Vous voyez une véritable boucle
d’économie circulaire
qui est une belle alternative
aux autres solutions.
Il faut garder en tête
que chaque producteur a ses spécificités.
Chaque territoire a ses caractéristiques,
ses attentes, ses besoins.
En matière de biodéchets,
mais plus largement,
quand on se pose la question
de notre impact sur l’environnement,
il n’y a pas de solution idéale unique.
C’est important de trouver des
solutions adaptées au cas par cas
et d’être ni dans une certaine forme
d’idéalisme qu’on voit aujourd’hui,
ni dans trop de scepticisme,
il faut passer à l’action.
Allons-y, on a les solutions,
passons à l’action.
Ça concerne plein de gens,
cette filière déchets,
le particulier qui va trier,
le collégien, le plongeur,
mais aussi le directeur
d’aménagement du territoire
parce qu’il faut aussi repenser
ses politiques
et les schémas historiques
de déchets, jusqu’à l’élu.
Donc je compte sur vous,
trions, valorisons
et valorisons au mieux
nos biodéchets alimentaires.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)